THOUSANDS, MAYBE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF INNOCENT LIVES WILL
BE SAVED.
HERE WITH MORE IS THE AWARD
WINNING ACTOR, FILM MAKER,
CO-FOUNDER OF CORE, HIS NAME IS
SEAN PENN.
HOW ARE YOU?
THANKS FOR COMING IN.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Sean: I MADE A PHONE CALL TO
YOU.
I READ THAT YOU WERE THERE.
THE STORY INTERESTED ME.
IF YOU WERE ON THIS SET, 99 OUT
OF 100 TIMES, WE PROBABLY WOULD
BE IN FULL DISAGREEMENT, RIGHT?
>> NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
>> Sean: SO I MADE THE FIRST
PHONE CALL TO YOU.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU REMEMBER.
I SAID I'M INTERESTED IN THE
WORK YOU'RE DOING AND EVEN
BEFORE THE WAR STARTED IN THIS
DOCUMENTARY YOU'RE DOING.
DO YOU REMEMBER WHAT YOU FIRST
SAID TO ME?
>> I DO.
>> Sean: WHAT DID YOU SAY?
>> I SAID I DON'T TRUST YOU.
>> Sean: IS THERE A REASONDOWN
DON'T TRUST ME?
>> A LOT OF REASONS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T TRUST
THEIR SPOUSE.
BUT YET WE HAVE TO GET ON WITH
LIFE.
I NEVER FELT THIS WAY ABOUT
WHERE OUR COUNTRY IS AND WHAT I
EXPERIENCED EMOTIONALLY IN
UKRAINE.
IT HAD NOT -- WE ALL TALK ABOUT
HOW DIVISIVE THINGS ARE, HOW
DIVIDED THINGS ARE HERE.
WHEN YOU STEP INTO A COUNTRY OF
INCREDIBLE UNITY, YOU REALIZE
WHAT WE'VE ALL BEEN MISSING.
I DON'T THINK I'VE GOT TIME TO
INDULGE MY LACK OF TRUST, WHICH
BECOMES A PETTY THING AS PET AND
BABIES ARE BEING VAPORIZED.
THESE PEOPLE ARE FIGHTING FOR
THE DREAMS AND ASPIRATION OF ALL
OF US AMERICANS.
WE TALKED ABOUT THAT, TOO.
>> Sean: WE HAD A LONG
CONVERSATION.
>> WE AGREED ON THAT.
WE HAVE TO --
>> Sean: WE'LL WORRY ABOUT
POLITICAL DISAGREEMENTS ANOTHER
DAY.
>> FAIR ENOUGH.
>> Sean: HERE'S WHAT I WANT TO
KNOW.
YOU WERE THERE IN NOVEMBER OF
2021.
OKAY.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT THE LEAD
UP TO THIS CONFLICT BY
POINT.
>> RIGHT.
>> Sean: WHY WERE YOU THERE
ORIGINALLY TO DO THE
DOCUMENTARY?
WHAT WAS IT ABOUT UKRAINE OR
MAYBE IT WAS ABOUT ZELENSKY THAT
INTERESTED YOU?
>> I THINK I WAS ON -- IN A
BETTER PART OF THE POPULATION OF
MOST AMERICANS, ANY
UNDERSTANDING OF UKRAINE.
WHAT WAS UKRAINE, WHERE IS
UKRAINE.
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF A PHONE
CALL BETWEEN PRESIDENT ZELENSKY
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP THAT WAS
MADE A LOT OF AND THE FACT THAT
PRESIDENT ZELENSKY HAD BEEN A
COMEDIC ACTOR THAT PLAYED A
CHARACTER THAT BECAME THE
PRESIDENT AND THEN BECAME THE
PRESIDENT.
WE WENT INITIALLY TO MAKE A
K
DOCUMENTARY THAT WOULD BRING
HOME A SENSE OF UKRAINE.
>> Sean: THERE'S THIS BUILD-UP
OF VLADIMIR PUTIN ON THE EASTERN
SIDE OF UKRAINE.
>> RIGHT.
>> Sean: YOU GOT -- FIRST WE
HAVE 50,000 TROOPS, THEN 100,000
TROOPS AND ALL THE MILITARY
EQUIPMENT.
YOU'RE CHRONICLING ALL OF THIS
AND YOU DEVELOP A RELATIONSHIP
WITH ZELENSKY.
>> YEAH.
>> Sean: TELL US ABOUT THIS WAS
UNFOLDING, A LOT OF THE WORLD
DIDN'T THINK THAT PUTIN WOULD DO
IT.
I DID THINK HE WOULD.
>> ALL THE EXPERTS THOUGHT TO
THOUGHT HE WOULD.
MOST OF THE EXPERTS THAT WERE
SPEAKING OUT IN THE UNITED
STATES INTELLIGENCE AGENCY AND
OTHERS FELT THAT HE WOULD.
I'LL TELL YOU TO THE LAST
MINUTE, I THINK A PART OF ME
THAT WANTED TO BE IN DENIAL OF
WHAT THAT WOULD MEAN.
TO UKRAINE AND ULTIMATELY TO THE
WORLD.
I THOUGHT REALLY?
IS THERE AN UPSIDE TO THIS?
WHAT I WASN'T REALLY SAVVY TO
WAS THAT I -- IN PARTICULAR, YOU
KNOW -- SO UNIVERSALLY THE
EXPERTS ON PUTIN FELT THIS WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN.
WHAT DIDN'T HAPPEN THEREFORE
WERE THE PREEMPTIVE SANCTIONS ON
ENOUGH OF A LEVEL BEFORE HE WAS
SO DEEP IN THAT THE HUMILIATION
WASN'T GOING TO LET IT STOP.
YOU WOULDN'T HAVE THE SIMPLICITY
OF NEGOTIATIONS FOR REGIONS TO
THE EAST OF MARIUPOL TO MAKE THE
BRIDGE FROM CRIMEA.
NOW IT'S THIS FULL-ON ASSAULT
AND HERE WE ARE.
>> Sean: PRIOR TO ZELENSKY, I
DIDN'T KNOW A LOT ABOUT ZELENSKY
LIKE A LOT OF PEOPLE UNTIL THE
INFAMOUS PHONE CALL.
I STILL TO THIS DAY THINK
THERE'S NOTHING TO THE PHONE
CALL.
SEPARATE ISSUE.
BE HAD TAKEN GEORGIA IN 08.
HE ANNEXED CRIMEA IN 2014.
HE HAS SHOWN A WILLINGNESS TO
ANNEX, TAKE OVER LAND, SHOWING
HIS TERRITORIAL AMBITIONS.
SO YOU GET THERE.
YOU'RE INTERVIEWING ZELENSKY AT
THIS TIME.
DID HE SEE THIS COMING?
DID HE BELIEVE THAT THIS WAS
REAL?
>> WELL, IT'S INTERESTING.
WE HAD MET INITIALLY ON A ZOOM
CALL.
>> Sean: DID YOU TRUST HIM?
>> I WAS REALLY INTERESTED TO
SEE WHO HE WAS.
>> Sean: EASY.
>> I DIDN'T HAVE A BAGGAGE WITH
HIM THAT I HAVE WITH YOU.
>> Sean: WHAT IS THE BAGGAGE?
WE NEVER MET BEFORE.
>> IT WAS A BADGE OF HONOR IN MY
HOUSE.
I HAVE THE FULL SCREEN THAT I
DOMINATED AN ENEMY OF THE STATE
WITH YOU.
>> Sean: I DON'T REMEMBER.
>> IT'S THE TRUTH.
BUT HERE'S WHAT HAPPENED.
BECAUSE OF COVID, ONCE WE HAD
GOTTEN -- I SENSED THAT HE WAS
VERY MUCH CONSIDERING GIVING US
SOME KIND OF ACCESS AND SPENDING
SOME TIME WITH US, WE WERE
DELAYED.
WE WERE DELAYED.
SO THEN WE WENT BACK.
WE STARTED SHOOTING IN NOVEMBER.
WE WENT TO MARIUPOL ON THE FRONT
LINES.
THEN WE ALSO WERE IN KYIV AND
TALKING TO MUSICIANS TO GET A
SENSE OF THE CULTURE.
THERE WAS THE WAGNER PROBLEM
THAT WAS GOING ON AT THE TIME.
SO THE ADMINISTRATION WAS
VERY -- WE COULDN'T SEE HIM.
WE CAME BACK.
THEN THIS THING REALLY
ESCALATED.
SO THEN WE WENT -- I THINK WE
GOT THERE ROUGHLY A WEEK BEFORE
THE INVASION.
WE MET HIM -- I MET HIM
FACE-TO-FACE FOR THE FIRST TIME
THE DAY BEFORE THE INVASION.
SPENT TIME WITH HIM, WHICH WE
DOCUMENT IN THE FILM DURING THE
INVASION ON THE DAY OF THE
INVASION.
I DON'T KNOW THAT THERE'S A
PERSON ON EARTH WHO COULD KNOW
THAT THEY WERE BORN FOR SUCH A
DAY, THAT THEY COULD RISE TO IT.
>> Sean: I WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE ON THE SAME PAGE.
WHEN YOU SAY INVASION, IS THIS
HIM TAKING THE TWO REGIONS,
DONBAS OR --
>> THERE WERE ROCKETS COMING IN.
THIS IS WHEN THEY TOOK THE
AIRPORT OUT OF KYIV.
SO IT WAS GAME ON.
SO -- IN HIM I SAW SOMETHING
THAT I HAVE NEVER SEEN BEFORE IN
MY LIFETIME THAT -- LIKE I SAID,
HAVING SEEN HIM, YES, PREPARED
FOR IT.
YES, HOPING AGAINST HOPE THAT IT
WOULD NOT HAPPEN.
A MAN WHO HAD NOT YET BEEN
CHALLENGED WITH IT'S HAPPENING.
THE NEXT DAY I SAW SOMETHING
THAT IS A MAN BUT A MAN WITH THE
ADRENALIZED -- HE'S THE FACE OF
SOMETHING THAT YOU SEE IN ALL OF
THE UKRAINIANS THAT WE SAW AND
TALKED TO, WHETHER THEY'RE IN
JUNE NORM, OUT OF UNIFORM,
SCHOOL TEACHERS, EVEN CHILDREN.
THIS EXTRAORDINARY COURAGE THAT
HAS COME UP.
IT WAS IN HIS EYES.
IT IS CLEAR TO ME THAT THE
UKRAINIANS WILL WIN THIS.
THE QUESTION IS AT WHAT COST.
>> Sean: DID THEY HAVE IN THE
EARLY HOURS -- I KNOW TRUMP GAVE
THEM JAVELINS.
THEY HAD SOME DEFENSES.
THEY WERE THE THIRD LARGEST
NUCLEAR POWER IN THE WORLD.
THEY MADE AN AGREEMENT THAT THEY
WOULD GIVE THOSE WEAPONS TO
RUSSIA TO BE DESTROYED IN
EXCHANGE FOR PROTECTION FROM
RUSSIA, GREAT BRITAIN AND THE
U.S.
LESSON TO BE LEARNED HERE, DON'T
GIVE UP YOUR NUCLEAR WEAPONS
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T BELIEVE PEOPLE
LIKE VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> EVEN COUNTRIES THAT HAVE
NUCLEAR WEAPONS CAN REMAIN
INTIMIDATED TO USE THEM.
I FEAR THAT LEGACY.
NOBODY WANTS TO SEE --
>> Sean: I DON'T WANT TO SEE
ONE.
>> AT THE SAME TIME IF ONLY ONE
BULLY WILL USE THOSE WEAPONS AS
A THREAT, WE HAVE TO RETHINK
WHAT WE'RING TO.
>> Sean: THE BUILD-UP, PUTIN
BROUGHT IN 10,000 TROOPS AND
20,000 AND UP TO 100,000 AND
IT'S CLEAR, TRANSPARENT AND
OBVIOUS THAT HE WAS GOING IN
WITH THE MILITARY EQUIPMENT.
I THOUGHT NATO COUNTRIES AND
WESTERN EUROPEAN COUNTRIES AND
THE IT IS SHOULD HAVE
ANTICIPATED WHAT WAS OBVIOUS AND
ARMING THE UKRAINIANS FOR THAT
MOMENT.
I DON'T THINK THEY WERE PREPARED
EITHER.
AM I WRONG?
>> LOOK, THIS COULD HAPPEN
TOMORROW ALSO.
THEY COULD GET F-16s IN THERE.
WE KNOW THAT FROM THE CALIFORNIA
NATIONAL GUARD THAT HAS HAD A
30-YEAR EXERCISE TRAINING WITH
UKRAINIAN AND WE WERE THERE WITH
THE UKRAINIAN AVIATORS JUST
SHORTLY BEFORE THEY WERE PULLED
OUT BECAUSE OF THE POLITICS AND
THE POLICIES RELATED TO THIS
IMPENDING INVASION, NOW
INVASION.
SO I THINK WE REALLY HAVE TO
RETHINK THIS.
AT THIS POINT, THESE ARE TRULY
HUMANITARIAN MECHANISMS.
>> Sean: I WANT TO -- I WANT TO
GO BACK TO THIS QUESTION.
POLAND OFFERED 28 OR 29 MIGS.
EVERYBODY SAYS THAT JOE BIDEN
VETOED THAT.
FORGET POLITICS.
I THINK HE MADE THE WRONG CALL.
>> Sean: NOBODY EVERYBODY CEASE
HE VETOED IT.
>> Sean: WHOEVER VETOED IT --
>> SOME PEOPLE SAY SOMETHING
THAT WAS MEANT TO BE COVERT GOT
LEAKED AND BAKE OVERT AND THAT
COMPROMISED THESE NATO PARTNERS.
WHAT MATTERS TO ME IS FOR A
SQUADRON, TWO SQUADRONS IS WHAT
IT WOULD TAKE FROM EVERYONE THAT
IS AN EXPERT TO END THIS THING.
THAT'S ABOUT THE $300 MILLION.
ONE BILLIONAIRE COULD PAY FOR
THOSE PLANES IF THE NATO
COUNTRIES WOULD LET THEM FLY IN.
>> Sean: I LOOK AT -- I'VE HAD
ARGUMENTS WITH A LOT OF MY
FRIENDS HERE.
I DO NOT BELIEVE -- I THINK IF
WE LEARNED FROM RECENT HISTORY
THAT POLITICIANS, REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS, THEY'RE ALL GUNG
HO.
THEY START THESE WARS.
THEY DON'T FIGHT THEM TO WIN
THEM.
THEY START THE WAR GUNG HO AND
POLITICIZE IT AND THEN WE LOSE
OUR NATIONAL TREASURE, OUR SONS
AND DAUGHTERS AND OTHERS COME
HOME WITH DEBILITATING INJURIES,
LOST LEGS, ARMS, DEFORMITIES
THAT YOU CAN IMAGINE.
I MET MANY OF THEM.
THEN THEY SAY NEVER MIND.
LIKE THE DISASTER IN
AFGHANISTAN, THEY PULL OUT.
I'M NOT FOR ONE BOOT ON THE
GROUND.
RONALD REAGAN HAD A DOCTRINE.
THAT WAS IN THE CASE OF THE
FORMER SOVIET UNION INNOVATING
AFGHANISTAN.
HE SUPPLIED MISSILES TO THEM AND
THEY DEFEATED THE SOVIET UNION.
I SUPPORT THAT DOCTRINE AND I
SUPPORT THE TRUMP DOCTRINE THAT
IF YOU FIGHT A WAR, YOU PUSH
BUTTONS USING NEW TECHNOLOGY AND
BOMB THE LIVING ADAM SCHIFF --
BOMB THE SCHIFF OUT OF --
>> I WOULD ARGUE YOU MADE THIS
POLITICAL AND GIVE ME A
CHANCE --
>> Sean: HOLD ON.
BAGHDADI AND SOLEIMANI DOCTRINES
THAT I BELIEVE IN.
IF WE APPLIED THAT HERE, I
BELIEVE UKRAINE WOULD WIN.
WHAT IS YOUR DOCTRINE?
>> HERE'S WHAT WE HAVE TO KNOW.
THE UKRAINIANS ARE FIGHTING TO
WIN.
THEY'RE FIGHTING FOR THE VERY
THING THAT WE'RE ABLE TO DO
RIGHT NOW TO BE FREE, TO DREAM.
THAT IS WHAT WE SAY WE REPRESENT
AS AMERICANS.
SO WE HAVE A GREAT EXAMPLE OF
FIGHTING TO WIN.
THERE'S ANOTHER PART OF IT
BECAUSE WE TALKED ABOUT THE
MILITARY PART OF IT.
THE CIVILIAN PART OF IT ALSO IS
THAT WE KNOW -- YOU SEE CONFLICT
ZONES, JOURNALISTS TRAGICALLY
SOME DIE.
I'M GOING TO FINISH MY POINT.
OVER AND OVER, WE CAN WATCH IT
ON TV.
WHY?
YOU CAN BE SMART.
YOU CAN KNOW WHERE THE STRATEGIC
ZONES ARE WHEN -- WHETHER IT'S A
TRADITIONAL WAR OR NOT.
PEOPLE CAN MOVE.
SO CAN AID.
SO ONE OF THE THINGS WE'RE NOT
SEEING BY ANY SCALE, U.N.
ORGANIZATIONS, OPERATING, THEY
CAN.
THEY TALK ABOUT SECURITY FOR AID
AND SUPPLIES BEING RESOURCED TO
CIVILIANS AND MILITARY.
FOR CIVILIANS, ARMORED VESTS ARE
IMPORTANT.
SO ONE OF THE THINGS I WANT TO
SAY JUST ABOUT WHAT IT IS BEING
THERE IS THAT OF COURSE THERE
ARE RISKS IN A CONFLICT ZONE.
BUT IT'S NOT WHAT WE PICTURE SO
AFTERNOON ABOUT A BUNCH OF HERE
WE COME TO SAVE THE DAY
FOREIGNERS.
YOU TAKE ONE CAR AND ONE TRUCK
OF SUPPLIES TO THAT BORDER, GIVE
THAT TRUCK AND THOSE SUPPLIES TO
UKRAINIANS WHO AREN'T GOING TO
LEAVE IF YOU ASK THEM TO.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE AT RISK WITH
OR WITHOUT OR HELP.
SO WE MIGHT AS WELL GIVE THEM
THE HELP.
THEY'LL SPRING THE SUPPLIES
WHERE THEY HAVE TO GO.
>> HOW IS THAT ANY DIFFERENT
THAN I'M SAYING SUPPLY THE
DRONES, SUPPLY THE JAVELINS,
SUPPLY THE STINGERS --
>> I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT
ANYBODY'S DOCTRINE.
>> Sean: NO.
THE ANTI-MISSILE SYSTEMS, THE
DEFENSE SYSTEMS, THE
ANTI-AIRCRAFT SYSTEMS.
AND I WOULD GIVE THEM THE MIGS.
SO WE'RE IN AGREEMENT.
>> WE ABSOLUTELY AGREE.
>> FIGHT THE WAR TO WIN IT.
DEFEAT RUSSIA OR --
>> OR LET THEM FIGHT IT TO WIN
IT.
THEY WILL.
>> Sean: LET THE UKRAINIANS
FIGHT THEMSELVES.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WE AGREE.
>> Sean: YOU'VE BEEN THERE A
LOT.
YOU WANT TO POLAND FOR A PERIOD
OF TIME.
AND I THINK MOST OF ANY AUDIENCE
AGREES, IF THE UKRAINIAN PEOPLE
SHOW THE VALOR, COURAGE,
WEAPONS, LET THEM WIN.
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT YOU'VE
SEEN WITH YOUR OWN EYES.
WE HAVE SEEN PICTURES EVERY
NIGHT.
WE HAVE A VIEWER ALERT.
IT'S HORRIFIC AND EVIL.
YOU HAVE SEEN THE MASS GRAVES.
WE'VE SEEN WHAT HAPPENED IN
MARIUPOL.
WE SEE WHAT HAPPENED JUST
OUTSIDE OF KIEV JUST IN THE LAST
TWO DAYS.
YOU HAVE SEEN HOSPITALS
TARGETED, NEIGHBORHOODS WIPED
OUT.
APARTMENT BUILDINGS WIPED OUT.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT YOU'VE SEEN.
HOW BAD IS IT WITH YOUR EYES
THAT YOU SIGN.
>> AS YOU TALKED ABOUT, I WAS
THERE ORIGINALLY IN NOVEMBER.
I WENT BACK AND WAS THERE,
WHATEVER IT IS, THE 37, WHATEVER
IT IS DAYS AGO WHEN THIS
INVASION STARTED MORE A
COUPLEDATION.
I WENT BACK LAST WEEK.
IT WAS TWO WEEKS AGO.
MY TIME GETS SCREWED UP WITH
THIS TRAIL TO LVIV.
YOU KNOW, I -- WHEN I MET WITH
PRESIDENT ZELENSKY, MY
COLLEAGUES AND I MAKING THE
DOCUMENTARY, WHEN WE WENT TO
MEET WITH HIM, WITH US MIDDAY.
YOU KNOW, WE KNEW THERE WERE
ROCKETS THAT WERE TARGETING
AREAS JUST OUTSIDE OF KIEV.
THAT THERE WERE AIR RAIDS,
SIRENS.
ULTIMATELY -- WHEN WE CAME OUT
OF WHERE WE MET WITH HIM, THERE
WAS A BLACK-OUT IN THE CITY.
BECAUSE OF CONCERNS ABOUT
ROCKETS.
WE WERE ENCOURAGED NOT TO USE
OUR AUTOMOBILE.
TO DRIVE BACK BECAUSE THE LIGHTS
COULD DRAW ROCKET FIRE.
WE WALKED.
BECAUSE OF THE EXPERIENCE OF
WHAT THIS FIGHT WAS ABOUT AND
SEEING IT IN THE FACES OF
LEADERSHIP AND NOT, THE ONLY
THING WE TALKED ABOUT, THE ONLY
THING WE FELT WAS THE DEEPEST
SENSE OF HEART BREAK FIRST FOR
THE UKRAINIANS WHO WERE GOING TO
FIGHT THE MAMED, THE INJURED IN
A WAR OF ATTRITION.
BUT VERY QUICKLY I THOUGHT THIS
ONE, THIS ONE, MY CHILDREN ARE
GOING TO FEEL IF THIS THING IS
NOT WON.
THEY'RE GOING TO FEEL IT IN
TANGIBLE WAYS IN THEIR LIFE.
OUR CHILDREN IN AMERICA.
THIS IS -- YOU AND I CAN ARGUE
ALL DAY AND I LOOK AT YOU AND I
THINK YOU BELIEVE IN YOUR
COUNTRY IN THIS WAY.
I BELIEVE IT IN MINE.
I THINK IT'S AT RISK.
THE GREAT DREAM OF IT, THE
ASPIRATION WITH ALL OF ITS
DIVERSITY.
UKRAINIANS HAVE A LOT OF DIVERSE
THOUGHT OVER THERE, TOO.
I THINK WE'RE REALLY AT RISK IF
WE LET THE GREATEST, MOST
HISTORIC IN OUR LIFETIME FIGHT
FOR DEMOCRACY AGAINST A GIGANTIC
SUPER POWER OF A MILITARY
INTIMIDATION --
>> Sean: THEY'VE DONE AMAZINGLY
WELL.
OUTMANNED, OUTGUNNED.
>> THAT'S WHAT I FELT FROM MY
TIME THERE.
GOING BACK, THE TRIP TO LVIV,
WHICH -- WITH THE DOCUMENTARY
TEAM, DRIVEN BY THE WORK WITH
CORE BECAUSE WE HAVE 200 STAFF
IN AND OUT OF UKRAINE, POLAND,
ROMANIA.
WHICH I WILL MAKE A CALL FOR
HELP.
WE NEED -- WE HAVE INCREDIBLE
REFUGEE, UKRAINIANS WORKING WITH
US IN THAT 200.
WE HAVE UKRAINIAN CITIZENS OF
POLAND AND ROMANIA AND OTHERS.
HALF OF OUR STAFF, THERE ARE NOW
HIRED UP JUST SINCE THIS TIME,
UKRAINIANS.
WHAT -- THAT TRIP WAS TARGETED
ON HOW TO GET SUPPLIES IN TO --
BY THE WAY, JUST FOR YOUR
AUDIENCE, THERE'S BEEN A LITTLE
SHIFT HERE IN THE HUMANITARIAN
WORLD, WHICH IS THAT UP TO LEVEL
4 VESTS, BODY ARMOR, THAT IS
APPROVED FOR HUMANITARIAN
ORGANIZATIONS --
>> Sean: AND I WILL SAY,
COUNTRIES -- POLAND HAS BEEN THE
MOST IMPRESSIVE IN THIS.
THEY'VE BEEN THE BRAVEST AND
DRAWN THE MOST POPULATION.
HERE'S WHAT I WANT TO SAY ABOUT
ZELENSKY.
I'VE BEEN VERY CRITICAL OVER THE
UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT.
IT STINKS TO HIGH HEAVEN.
SEPARATE ISSUE FOR A SEPARATE
DAY.
I WATCHED THIS COMEDIAN GET
ELECTED ON ENDING CORRUPTION
PLATFORM.
THIS ALL STARTS UNFOLDING.
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT IMPRESSED ME
ABOUT HIM.
YOU MET HIM.
I HAVEN'T.
THERE'S BEEN MANY LEADERS IN THE
WORLD IN SIMILAR SITUATIONS AS
HE'S BEEN IN, OFFERED ASYLUM,
EVEN OFFERED ASYLUM HERE'S BY MY
SOURCES.
THEY GET IN A PRIVATE JET, PACK
IT WITH CASH, SOLD AND SILVER,
HIGH HEELED SHOES AND GET THEIR
ASS OUT.
HE DIDN'T DO THAT.
HE PUT ON HIS BODY ARMOR AND
WENT AROUND THE WORLD BEGGING
FOR HELP FROM THE WORLD.
NOT BOOTS ON THE GROUND.
HE'S ASKING FOR MUNITIONS AND
HUMANITARIAN ASSISTANCE.
THAT IMPRESSES ME.
MOST -- MANY OTHER LEADERS
WOULDN'T HAVE DONE THAT.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE LAST THOUGHT
ON HIM AND WHAT YOU THINK THEY
NEED THE MOST.
I'LL LET YOU SUM IT UP.
>> I TALKED TO THE MAYOR OF
KYIV, FORMER WORLD HEAVYWEIGHT
CHAMPION.
>> Sean: I READ ABOUT THEM.
>> THIS WAS IN NOVEMBER.
THIS IS SOMEBODY THAT VERY WELL
COULD HAVE RUN AGAINST ZELENSKY
IN THE NEXT ELECTION AND PERHAPS
BEATEN HIM.
WE TALKED TO A LOT OF PEOPLE
THAT SEEM TO BE THE CONSENSUS
THAT THIS WOULD BE COMPETITIVE.
HE DIDN'T HAVE A LOT OF PRAISE
FOR THE PRESIDENT.
TONIGHT, AS WE'RE SITTING HERE,
THAT SAME VERY POWERFUL FIGURE,
KLITCHKO HAS ENLISTED IN
PRESIDENT ZELENSKY THAT
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF'S MILITARY.
HE'S IN THE FIGHT.
SO THAT TELLS YOU EVERYTHING.
THIS IS LEADERSHIP.
WE TALKED ABOUT LEADERSHIP, WE
TALKED TO LEADERS.
NO ONE ON THE PLANET HAS BEEN
TESTED IN LEADERSHIP LIKE THIS
ONE HUMAN BEING.
>> Sean: YOU'RE REALLY EMOTIONAL
ABOUT THIS.
>> YEAH.
>> Sean: AS A CONSERVATIVE,
FORGET OUR POLITICAL
DIFFERENCES, I DON'T WANT TO SEE
ONE MORE DEAD KID IN THE STREET,
ONE MORE INNOCENT WOMAN OR MAN
DEAD.
I DON'T WANT TO SEE MORE IMAGES
IN MY LIFETIME OF MASS GRAVES
LIKE WE'RE SEEING.
>> THERE OR IN CHICAGO FOR THAT
MATTER.
>> Sean: ANYWHERE.
I DON'T WANT TO SEE IT.
WE CAN FIX ALL OF THESE PROBLEMS
IF WE HAVE THE WILL AND THE
DESIRE TO.
WE'RE THE GREATEST COUNTRY ON
EARTH.
I THINK UKRAINIANS WILL WIN.
WESTERN EUROPE AND AMERICA HAS
TO SUPPLY THEM WITH THE WEAPON
TO WIN.
THAT IS FOLLOWING THE REAGAN
DOCTRINE EVEN THOUGH YOU DON'T
CARE ABOUT DOCTRINE.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE HANNITY
DOCTRINE IS?
IF YOU INVADE A SOVEREIGN
COUNTRY, YOU FORFEIT YOU'RE
RIGHT TO LEAD A COUNTRY AND YOU
FORFEIT YOUR RIGHT TO LIVE.
MEANING VLADIMIR PUTIN HAS
FORFEITED HIS RIGHT TO LIVE.
LAST WORD.
>> I THINK WHAT WOULD BE MOST
INTERESTING ABOUT THAT
CONVERSATION IS ASK THOSE
GENERALS, THOSE MILITARY
COMMANDERS IN RUSSIA, THAT HAVE
ALSO BEEN SANCTIONED AND GOING
TO THE UNITED STATES FOR
EDUCATION OR ENGLAND OR OTHER
PLACES.
I AM -- I DON'T WANT TO INVEST
IN THE CONVERSATION, NOT THAT I
DON'T HAVE IT PRIVATELY ABOUT MY
FEELINGS ABOUT WHAT DIRECT
ACTION SHOULD HAPPEN TO A LEADER
THAT DOES THAT.
BUT IF THERE IS A GOD, THERE
WILL BE VENGEANCE BEYOND ALL
POSSIBLE COMPREHENSION.
>> Sean: VENGEANCE IS MINE
SAYETH THE LORD QUOTED IN A
FAMOUS BOOK.
I HOPE THIS WAR ENDS SOON AND I
HOPE THEY ARE VICTORIOUS AND I
HOPE PUT TIN GETS PIT BACK IN
THE GRAVE THAT HE DESERVES FOR
DOING THIS AND I HOPE IT STOPS
HERE.
>> BY THE WAY, YOU'RE NEVER
GOING TO DO IT, BUT YOU'RE
INVITED -- YOU'RE INVITED --
YOU'LL NEVER TALK POLITICS WITH
ME WILL YOU?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
WE'RE IN A DIFFERENT --
>> Sean: IT WASN'T BAD.
DO YOU TRUST ME NOW MORE THAN
YOU DID?
>> I'M NOT GOING TO WEIGH-IN ON
THE PUTIN THING.
>> Sean: YOU SAID -- I DON'T
TRUST YOU.
THAT'S WHAT YOU SAID TO ME.
DID I KEEP MY WORD?
>> YOU ABSOLUTELY KEPT YOUR
WORD.
>> Sean: SO WHY DON'T YOU TRUST
ME?
>> YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENS?
THERE'S A LOT OF PHYSICAL
THERAPY NECESSARY AFTER A BIG
CAR ACCIDENT.
DON'T GET IT DONE IN A DAY.
>> Sean: OUR PRAYERS ARE WITH
INNOCENT VICTIMS OF THIS
CONFLICT THAT ARE DYING.
I WISH YOU LUCK.
>> AND THE HEROS WE'RE FIGHTING
FOR.